he was an academic and a politician who
for years took an uncompromising stance
with hardline policies but all that
changed when david trimble surprised
allies and critics by leading northern
ireland's unionist pro-british majority
into a peace deal with nationalists and
republican opponents
a towering figure in northern ireland
and british politics he became the
architect of the good friday agreement
it helped end three decades of sectarian
and political violence known as the
troubles where the guerrilla group the
ira was fighting british forces and
pro-british paramilitary groups
not just to bring about the end to
terrorist violence but also to end what
has in effect been a cold war
between the two parts of ireland
over the course of the last 75 years and
to a lesser extent a cold war between
the republic of ireland and the united
kingdom
the good friday agreement brokered by
the u.s during bill clinton's presidency
marked a turning point
and in 1998 as ulster unionist party
leader trimble won the nobel peace prize
shared with his catholic adversary john
hume
that same year he was elected as the
first minister of northern ireland in a
new power sharing parliament
but animosity and criticism followed
many in northern ireland grew tired of
trimble and his colleagues
he was eventually eclipsed when the
hardline reverend ian paisley went on to
share power with shin fein the political
wing of the ira
despite a combative personality trimble
earned the respect of many for reaching
beyond religious and political lines
david trimble was 77 years old